we begin with breaking news this
afternoon metro police confirming a
suspect is now
dead following an hours-long barricade
in the southeast part of town this all
happened at an apartment complex near
silverado ranch
and maryland parkway good afternoon
thank you so much for joining us i'm
kirsten joyce
and i'm christian casadas metro police
say this all started as an officer
involved shooting
orco manha joins us live from the scene
with the latest details orko
well christian and kirsten metro police
sources confirming with us this
afternoon
that the person involved in all of this
is now dead now take a look at the scene
here behind me
it was a very fluid situation all day
today and you can see
police are still on scene diverting
traffic into the different areas here
near silverado ranch and pollock road
and all of this happening here at the
milan apartment town homes
per metro sources now metro police were
investigating an officer-involved
shooting here this morning
just before 10 a.m metro tells us that
they were responding to a domestic
situation
between a man and a woman the man shot
at police and officers fired back
no officers were injured and it's
unclear if the suspect was hit
police say the man then barricaded
himself inside his residence at the
milan apartment town homes
and we're told the swat team was called
out a metro source telling us
that man also fired to the apartment
burning some of his
own animals and again back out here live
you can see
the situation here still unfolding at
this hour
again police telling us that the person
involved in all this is now dead
but as you can see metro police are
still blocking part of the road here
this section of silverado ranch
boulevard but there are some cars able
to turn left and right
so of course we're going to stay on this
story and bring you the latest
developments as they happen for now
reporting live
orca mana 8 news now